all right welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
logistics first of all please build
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions
uh you can actually you know
you know the speaker today wants to do
this interactively on the fly so you're
welcome to do so all right the second
today's ddps seminar is open to external
audiences and so no classified
discussion and finally the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
youtube channel so that's about it now
let me introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host professor florian
who is the khalsi
assistant professor of mechanical
engineering at the university of houston
he received his uh the bachelor's degree
in science in mechanical engineering and
um
uh ba degree in economics from the
cornell university and his master's and
phd
degree in mechanical and aerospace
engineering from princeton university
where he graduated as the porter
ogden
jacob
jacobus fellow
his research is at the inter
intersection of fluid mechanics and
nonlinear dynamics with interest in
bio-inspired locomotion and using data
to model and control dynamical systems
today danielle will give a talk about
charting dynamics from data please
expect a wonderful talk and enjoy it
now without further ado let me pass the
button to daniel by asking our usual
question that is what is your favorite
things to do other than research
oh uh well i really enjoy playing
basketball watching playing basketball
everything about that so yeah oh wow
okay so the nba playoff is going to um
start soon yeah i guess
just another week or so left so i'm
excited about that as well wonderful
wonderful okay the stage is yours
okay thank you youngster so much for the
introduction and and thank you everyone
for joining me today um so today i'm
going to be talking about uh something
i'm calling charting dynamics from data
and we'll see
exactly what that means
but before getting to the talk i just
wanted to say a little bit about myself
and the group so i just joined the
university of houston this past october
and so my group is brand new and we're
just really starting out our own
research
and so i want to say a little bit about
exactly what we do
so my website is is listed up here
defloren.github.com.io
and if you go there you'll see some of
the things that we're interested on so
you also mentioned we worked at the
intersection of fluids and nonlinear
dynamics with interest in bioinspire
locomotion
learning structure and complex systems
as well as how fluids and thermal
effects interact especially in
environmental contexts
and we're looking for people both
students and postdocs to join and i'm
really keen to talk uh to potential
collaborators and people who just work
on interesting things as i'm sure
everyone in this audience does so
if anything today is even of a little
bit of interest to you please do reach
out to me i have my email up here and
i'll also
have it up on the screen at the end of
the talk
okay so uh just before getting started i
also want to
acknowledge
mike graham from the university of
wisconsin-madison
who is
collaborate on on this work as well as
the af star and onr for funding this
work
so
today's talk is going to be
all about dynamical systems in a very
broad sense
and dynamical systems of course are
fundamental to our ability to model
processes
in engineering and the sciences
and just a couple of examples that uh
you know i'm sure we're all familiar
with are uh for one newton's second law
right so uh using newton's second law we
can derive governing equations for how
objects move
um an example that's become more
prevalent in the last
few years our sir models to model
disease spread and of course there are
many more examples where we use ideas
from dynamical systems to develop models
of the real world and uh
and the manufacturing world as well
so dynamical systems are very useful for
understanding
nature and things that people construct
but there are a number of challenges as
well
for one governing equations might be
unknown
or only partially known
and it might also be the case that we
don't even have recourse to first
principles to actually derive equations
of motion
beyond that we might have very
non-linear behavior
and even if we can derive equations uh
the systems that we get might be so high
dimensional to the point of being
difficult to analyze and prohibitively
expensive to make predictions with
and something i think is really
emblematic of this is uh
well here's a mesh of a global climate
of a global climate model and you can
see just how enormous uh this system
will be how many degrees of freedom it
will have and actually uh
trying to make predictions with this is
incredibly expensive and
and uh prohibitive to do basically
uh so even in the face of these
challenges what we often do have
recourse to
is data and it's often very rich data
and so can we somehow use this data to
ameliorate some of the challenges that
we face
and this motivates
the sort of main theme or goal behind
two days talk which is to develop simple
dynamical models
directly from data
and the emphasis here is on simplicity
okay
so
this alone and the fact that we have
data doesn't really
immediately solve the challenges that we
face
data can still be
very complex it can it can reflect very
complex behavior and it can also be very
high dimensional
but what we do know is that there are
these key enablers
that are present which is that patterns
often exist in data especially data that
comes from dynamical systems
and a really neat example of this
is shown in this movie here so
this is a movie taken by a satellite of
the flow
over the island of guadalupe okay so we
see cloud coverage over the island and
there's wind blowing from left to right
and we see the emergence of these
large-scale patterns we see
vortex shedding behind this entire
island
and these sorts of patterns enable low
dimensional representations of our
systems
and
thereby allow us to develop simple
dynamical models
okay so we have dynamical systems that
might be very complex and high
dimensional and patterns exist in them
but how do we use this sort of
information to
to get by the challenges that i
mentioned
so
the reason that patterns emerged is
because natural systems tend to live on
small or low dimensional manifolds
okay
and i mean uh manifolds in state space
so here's the picture that i want you to
keep in mind say that we have a very
high dimensional state space
and we fill that with a bunch of
particles so each particle here
represents
a possible state of the system
and as we let these particles move under
the dynamics
then what we see oftentimes is that very
quickly these particles uh become
attracted to a subset of this state
space or in this case become attracted
to this uh
this doughnut shaped manifold okay and
this is even true for infinite
dimensional systems like the ones that
we get from pd's and the mechanism that
makes this happen is dissipation
so when dissipation is present there
often exists a finite dimensional
attracting set that's called
an inertial manifold and this inertial
manifold is where the long time dynamics
live okay and in some cases you can
formally prove that this exists
and uh in other cases we sort of
implicitly uh assume that this is
something that that exists
so now that we have this picture in mind
that dynamics are attracted to it and
eventually live on these lower
dimensional manifolds
we can go back to our original goal and
make it a little bit more precise
okay so the way that we're going to
to attain this goal
is by a two-step process
first what we'll do is find the manifold
where the dynamics find this lower
dimensional set embedded in this very
high dimensional state that everything
is attracted to
and the way that we'll do this is by
learning a coordinate transformation
from the high dimensional coordinates
to the low dimensional coordinates that
are valid on the manifold and these low
dimensional coordinates can be thought
of as
the essential dynamical variables
now once we have this manifold in hand
then what we can do is learn the
dynamics
on the manifold in the low dimensional
coordinates and this will give us a low
dimensional ideally minimal dimensional
model
for the dynamics of our system
okay so uh so this is what we're going
to do and i guess a natural question
that arises is how do we actually find
this manifold what's uh what's the way
to do it what's the best way to do it
what should we do
so there are many ways to
to learn a manifold i've listed some of
the
non-linear manifold learning methods
here that are quite popular so
kernel pca is one
iso map locally linear embedding
laplacian imf's hessian eigenmaps t-sne
autocoders and and there's a very large
list of these sort of methods
and
intuitively what all these well
intuitively the way that we think of a
manifold is as a sort of curved surface
that's embedded in a volume so i'll be
using this this donut here as as a
representative of what a manifold is we
have a surface of a donut this curved
surface that's living in
three-dimensional space in this case
and the way that all of these
manifold learning methods work at least
intuitively is that they basically all
try to flatten a manifold right
you take something curvy and you try to
make it flat or euclidean
but
what you'll find
with any of these methods
is a problem which is that
the mappings that they produce are not
injective
and here's what i mean by that let's say
that we
we look at this taurus manifold on the
right
and let's color the top half red and the
bottom half blue so all so we know that
this uh taurus the surface of it is
two-dimensional right it's it's just uh
it's just a surface in a
three-dimensional space and so we should
be able to
come up with a two-dimensional
representation or reduce this torus to a
two-dimensional space
and so all these manifold learning
methods they try to flatten this source
and what you'll find is no matter what
which way you try to flatten this thing
it'll collapse on top of each other and
what happens now is that you can no
longer distinguish the top from the
bottom you can't distinguish the blue
from the red
and so
since you can't distinguish the top from
the bottom the blue from the red you
can't recover the torus from this
flattened annulus now okay and so in
trying to reduce the dimension here
we've actually lost information this
mapping is not injected it's mapped
different points to the same points and
we have no way to recover um
our original object
so uh
to figure out how to actually counter
this problem we'll have to understand
manifolds a little bit more deeply
okay
so what is a manifold really
our working representation of a manifold
danielle there's a
there's a question by pat and he asked
about
are you assuming the manifold can be
described as a set of simple equations
or in a more complex way say using
locally weighted regression
uh i'm just assuming a manifold
i don't necessarily need an equation
i i think the next slide this coming
slide will actually uh
say what i mean by that yeah if not then
we can uh keep going with the question
okay so the way that we're going to
think of a manifold is as what's known
as an atlas of charts
so there are two keywords here an atlas
and a chart and i'll explain what each
of those means
so a chart is something that has two
ingredients
the first ingredient is called a
coordinate domain and what this is is an
open subset on the manifold think of it
as this little red patch of this taurus
here
and then the second ingredient is
something called a coordinate map and
what this is is a continuous and
invertible map that takes us
from the coordinate domain from this red
patch to a subset of euclidean space of
the same dimension as the manifold so
here we're taking this patch that's
embedded in three-dimensional space and
mapping it to this flat two-dimensional
space
so the way to think of this uh
coordinate map is that something that
takes a patch
and then flattens it
okay so that's what a chart is and then
an atlas is just
a collection of charts
that together together cover the entire
manifold so in addition to this red or
pink one i can have a blue one and i can
keep adding more and more until i've
covered the entire manifold
okay
and what will be especially relevant for
us since we're thinking about dynamics
is you know as your uh
as your state is evolving along a
manifold you might move from one patch
to another
and so
what we'll have to be able to do is come
up with a way to transition
between these low dimensional patches
between
the flat red patch and this flat blue
patch and we can do that by
composing these coordinate maps and
their inverses to uh to transition
between these low dimensional
representations
okay so the way to really think of a
manifold is as a collection of patches
that can together be flattened
and this sort of representation is
minimal dimensional so if you don't use
patches
if you just try to
flatten the entire thing at once then
you cannot get to the true or the
intrinsic dimension of the manifold
so let's go back to our taurus example
that we tried to unsuccessfully flatten
before
and what we'll do now is
before trying to flatten this thing
we'll first break it up into a
collection of patches
okay
then we separate each patch
and now that we have uh each each little
piece individually we can flatten these
no problem nothing collapses on top of
itself we now have
local two-dimensional representations of
each patch and we can invertedly go back
to our curved manifold
so this is how these ideas work and
the next question is how can we actually
implement this sort of approach when all
that we have is a collection of data
so the way that we implement this is as
follows
okay so uh what we're going to assume
that we have is time series data it can
either be one long time series or
several sets of time series and we'll
assume that the data lie on or near a
manifold and then we follow a three-step
procedure
in the first step we cluster the data
into overlapping patches
and this gives us our overlapping
coordinate domains so everything for
everything that i'm showing today
we've used k-means and then an
additional procedure to make the
resulting clusters overlap so when we
cluster our data we sort of implicitly
build these patches
so once we have these patches
the next step is to learn how to flatten
each patch
okay
so
so for each patch what we'll do is we'll
approximate the coordinate map that i
mentioned
and this is the coordinate map that
takes from high dimensional space to a
low dimensional space and we'll
approximate it using the neural neural
network since uh since we have these
universal approximation theorems or
properties
and we simultaneously learn both the
neural network or
we simultaneously train a neural network
to approximate this coordinate map as
well as its inverse so we can map
forward to this lower dimensional space
and backward
to the ambient dimension
and together these two neural networks
form something that's called an auto
encoder or an auto
an under completed autoencoder that
i'm sure many of you are familiar with
so now what we have is a way to
[Music]
reduce the dimension of our data to a
minimal dimension
and now that we have this low
dimensional or minimal dimensional
representation of that we can now learn
the dynamics in these low dimensional
coordinates so finally for each patch we
now have time series data in the reduced
space and we learned the dynamics
in this reduced space from this time
series data okay so
the dynamics are still non-linear in the
low dimensional coordinates and so we
will approximate them
using neural networks to learn either
either ordinary differential equations
for the dynamics or time delta t
flow maps
okay
and this is our entire method in a
nutshell and really the key here is this
decomposition of everything into patches
um and i also mentioned that we use auto
encoder so in case you're not familiar
with this
i don't know what an autoencoder is it
basically tries to
take an input and reconstruct it as
perfectly as possible but with a
bottleneck in the middle to to get sort
of a
you know the basic representation of
what your object is
okay so uh to show how these things or
how this method works i want to take you
through
a
handful or it's more than a handful of
examples and we'll start with something
really simple and then in the end get to
something that's uh that's quite
complicated
so the first for the first very simplest
example i just want you to think of a
particle that's moving around in a
circle
okay so we just have a particle that's
moving at a constant speed
around a circle
and our data consists of
40 points equally spaced around the
circle and we have x and y coordinates
for each point
so our data is two dimensional since we
have the x and the y coordinates but we
know that a circle is really a
one-dimensional object right it's just a
curve that's uh that connects to itself
and so
we should be able
to get a one-dimensional dynamical model
since this is a one-dimensional manifold
that this data and the dynamics slip on
and so let's see how everything works so
just following our procedure the first
thing that we do is
break this data up into patches so
in this case we've broken it up into
three patches a red one a blue one and a
yellow one and then we also
make sure that these patches overlap
we then take each of these patches or
the data in each patch and we train auto
encoders to find
reduced representations of the data here
so we can map invertibly
back and forth from this
two-dimensional ambient space
to a one-dimensional latent space
and in principle this is losses in
principle we can do this without losing
any information
and finally once we have our data
in the
in the one-dimensional space the reduced
space here then we can train
our neural networks for the dynamics
in uh in these reduced spaces
so once we have our
our local dynamical models we can then
patch them all together to get
global dynamics for this system
and let's see how this works so
in this last plot here on the right what
i've done is just taken an initial
condition somewhere on the circle
map that through the low dimensional but
one dimensional space
and then
evolve the state of the system using our
learned one-dimensional dynamical model
and so what we see
are these points so the points come from
our trained dynamical model
and if you can see there's a gray curve
on top of these points and
and uh if you can't see it and then
you'll just have to trust me that
there's
almost a perfect overlap between our
trained dynamical model and and the true
dynamics of the system
and what i want you to notice especially
is that we have these smooth transitions
as we go from one patch to another so as
you change from yellow to blue from blue
to red and from red to yellow we see
very nice smooth transitions so on the
top plot i've just shown the first cycle
of the motion
and then on the bottom plot all the way
down to uh 1000 times steps out of the
motion um and so we get this really nice
high fidelity model you can see that
maybe the phase speed is a little bit
off but that's to be expected and can be
improved with further training for
example
hey danielle there is a another question
by pat he asked how many samples do you
need for these simple examples i'm
guessing the the sample complexity will
much higher for harder problems
yes
so i guess you need to cover your
manifold
so
that will scale with the dimension of
the underlying manifold
right so even if you have
your ambient space is very high
dimensional but your manifold is low
dimensional then the sample complexity
should scale with that
intrinsic dimension of the manifold
but since you don't know the underlying
dimension of the
yeah so that's
that's the tricky thing so you don't
know beforehand
the answer
right all right
sounds good
okay
um so so this is how things work for the
very simplest example that i could think
of and now let's make sure sorry if you
asked how many samples do you need here
for this specific example okay in this
case uh 40 samples
but i think you could get away with less
but that's what was used here
so
40 samples which was one
one uh
one rotation around the circle
okay got it revolution around the circle
okay
okay uh so let's let's make things
slightly just slightly more complex
and now we'll have a particle that's
moving around the surface of a torus
and it moves uh periodically so so it
forms this little coil
around the surface of the torus and it
has this periodic orbit okay so it's
basically the same thing now except we
have
an orbit that's a little bit more
complicated and the ambient dimension is
three but again this is a periodic orbit
so
we know that we should be able to find a
one-dimensional representation this this
is something that's still topologically
a circle so we should find a
one-dimensional representation and we
just follow our procedure exactly like
we did in the last example so we break
our data up into patches here again i've
used three patches a red one a blue one
and a yellow one
we then take each of those patches and
independently learn how to
reduce the dimension to one since we
know that we should be able to do that
in this case
and now that we have our time series
data in the reduced spaces we again
learn
dynamical models in the reduced space
and let's see how this works so again we
take an initial condition and evolve it
forward in time using our learn
dynamical model and compare it to uh to
the true dynamics in the gray line and
again we see that we have a very good
agreement so on the top i'm showing
the first period
and on the bottom up to the 10th period
of motion and we have a very good
agreement i think i'm seeing other
questions pop up yeah another question
by jack
how does this approach work for
non-integrable systems that is system
has no period
okay i will show you something that does
not have a period
great
any other questions
no
it's just comments a lot of questions
okay sure
okay so let's go
uh a little bit more complicated now
uh so now we're going to have still a
particle moving around the surface of a
taurus but now the uh
the periods of motion in the toroidal
and colloidal directions are
incommensurate so we no longer get
something that's periodic we instead get
something that's uh quasi-periodic and
if you let this
if you let this particle move forever
it'll densely fill the surface of this
torus
okay so now we have something that's
living on the surface of the torus
normally the the data is
three-dimensional
but we know that we should be able to
find a two-dimensional representation
since it's on the surface of the torus
and so what we do is we
split our data up into these patches
again so this time i've used six patches
there's a red one a blue one and a
yellow one at the top and then green
purple and orange on the bottom
and then in the bottom left i'm just
showing how we make these different
patches overlap with each other and you
can see that
several points are actually members of
several patches
but once we have that we can then
separate all the patches
and then we can learn how to map each
patch
to
a low dimensional in this case
two-dimensional space
and we do that using auto-encoders to
invertebrately make that mapping and
again now that we have our data in this
low dimensional space we learn the
dynamics
in the lower two-dimensional space and
then we can see
how this compares to ground truth
dynamics so again we take an initial
condition
that's on the surface of our manifold we
evolve it forward in time using our
learn dynamical model and compare that
to the true dynamics so
uh the top two plots on the right here
those show the x y and z coordinates uh
so the the points show what our model
gives and then the gray lines show the
true dynamics and then on the bottom two
plots i've reconstructed the two angles
since that might be easier to interpret
you can see that we're doing
quite well the face speeds are a little
bit off so you can see that in the
bottom right plot right how the
the points are a little bit shifted away
from the gray lines but overall uh
this is uh you know we're very happy
with the sort of reconstruction that we
can get and and the key point here is
that we're getting something that's
minimal dimensional so
if you don't do this sort of
decomposition into patches you
will never be able to get something
that's two-dimensional
is that what
well okay another question from me how
many pet do you know
how do you know how many passes do you
have to
use okay yeah so i can tell you
for a taurus you would need
let's see how many would you you would
need at least three patches for taurus
now this is sort of a tricky thing you
don't know beforehand how many patches
you actually need
okay so that that's highly dependent on
the geometry of your data and so in
general that's something that you would
have to sort of
empirically figure out
there may be
smarter ways to figure out how many
patches you need so i know that there is
an ever increasing set of tools
for trying to figure out the geometry of
data sets so tools like that
could potentially
provide some sort of insight into into
how many patches you need but in general
you don't know beforehand now what you
could do is just start with many patches
and then sort of iteratively reduce the
number of patches that you get
and at some point um
you won't be able to map to a low
dimension anymore okay so so the nice
thing about
these these manifolds or
the manifolds that come from dynamical
systems is that the dimension of it is a
global property
so that means that each patch has to
have the same dimension
and so you could just sort of figure out
the dimension
of just one patch of the data and use
that to judge whether you can decrease
the number of patches or not and whether
you can decrease the dimension of the
system or not so you can sort of
figure things out locally and then apply
apply that globally
all right sounds good
okay um
so let's again move to a slightly more
complicated example
so uh here
we're going to be dealing with a
reaction
diffusion system so this is given by
two pdes for two fields u and v
um it looks more complicated than it is
it's just a diffusion term
on the right of the equation and then a
cubic non-linearity for the other terms
and under the right conditions what
you'll get is a nice spiral wave that
forms okay so if i play this animation
uh these are the sort of dynamics that
you get from this reaction diffusion
system just this nice periodic wave that
spirals out
okay so i showed uh
two movies here right one on the left
and one on the right
so the one one of them is from the data
and then the other one is from our
learned model
and if i play it again
i think you'll have a hard time actually
distinguishing
which is
which so it turns out that the one on
the left has a dimension of a bit over
20 000
and the one on the right has a dimension
of one
and this is the sort of reduction that
you can get by using this this patching
approach so again we we patched the data
up into separate patches and learned
local dynamical models for each patch
and then sewed everything together to
get these global dynamics that i showed
in the animation here
okay so that's just to show that this
works i guess not surprisingly and in
higher dimensions as well
um
so let's start to get a little bit more
complicated so
[Music]
we can basically do the same thing for
other pd's so here's the kermodo
civicinski pd
it's you know one of its uses is to
model flame front dynamics and you can
get a very nice rich set of dynamics
from this pd
so here's another example where we have
just some simple periodic dynamics okay
so this is the data that i'm showing now
and the colored bars up top show how
how we've patched this into three
patches in state space
this is the reconstruction so we can map
things to one dimension since we know
this is a one-dimensional manifold
the reconstruction is very good and if
we look at
the evolution
of an of an initial condition using our
learned model
we see basically
a
very high fidelity behavior that's
almost perfectly matches what you would
get um in the true dynamical system
okay so this is still periodic so it's
not uh i guess i lied a little bit this
wasn't more complicated than the
previous exam example
but this next one will be so now we're
going to look at the
chaos equation but we'll
change the hyper diffusion coefficient
so that we get dynamics with disparate
time scales okay
so
here i'm showing just a heat map
okay so the vertical coordinate is
that's the spatial coordinate and then
the x-axis is the
that's just time
and what you can see is this very
slow drifting behavior right
and this longer plot is over 100 time
units and if i zoom into one time unit
which is this plot on the upper right
you can see this much faster these much
faster beating dynamics okay so we now
have these uh these disparate time
scales that are
you know a factor of 100 different
and what we do in this case is we
actually know that there's a symmetry
present in the system
there's a translational equal variance
in the system and so what we do is we
factor that symmetry out by separating
this data
into a shape variable in the middle here
and then a phase variable on the bottom
okay
so when we do this the shape variable
now that's just something
periodic or quasi-periodic and the phase
variable we we have this periodic
behavior again with this slow drift as
well
okay
and so what do we do now
we take
one time unit
of the data
that's what we use to train okay so one
time unit is enough to capture the fast
beating dynamics
but
it's a very small fraction of this sort
of slow drift period but nevertheless
we'll just use one period
of data for our training
we can again map this to to
to one dimension
and then when we reconstruct things
we see that we're actually able to get
these fast beating dynamics on the
bottom right
as well as these slow
drifting dynamics
in the middle here so even though we've
only used one time unit of data we
nevertheless capture
both of these features
okay
so i have one last example that i want
to show you which is uh
which has the most complex dynamics of
all the examples
and we're still going to be dealing with
the
ks system
but now it'll be in a regime where we
have intermittent dynamics
so what the space time plot looks like
is this so as you move from left to
right as you move forward in time
you sort of go from these almost
quasi-steady or quasi-stable cellular
states
and there's a very fast burst onto
another
sort of quasi-stable cellular system and
you sort of burst
back and forth between these cells
if we look at a state-space projection
of this then we'll get a little bit more
intuition for what's going on okay so i
i'm going to take this data
and just for the purpose of
visualization i'll project it onto the
leading three fourier coefficients
and when we do that these are the sort
of dynamics that we see okay so the the
red point is showing the dynamics and
this blue skeleton is showing the the
manifold that we're evolving on
and what you see is that we burst
between these two saddle points on the
left and the right and when we're
bursting it's basically randomly
choosing which of these branches
it's bursting along so we have these
complicated non-periodic dynamics now
and again some of the key challenges
here is that we have disparate time
scales we have these fast bursts in
between these quiets and cells there's a
very thin state space structure it's
almost it's cage-like i would say and we
have very sensitive uh non-periodic
dynamics so this is going to be
something that's quite challenging to
capture with a low dimensional model
okay nevertheless we move forward so we
take our data
in this case we patch it up into six
patches the way that i determine the
number of patches to use in this example
was
by looking at that at that projection
that i showed on the last slide so we
saw this sort of
cage-like structure and so we decided to
to patch them to six patches one for
each of uh of the saddle points so red
on the left blue on the right
and then another patch for each of these
heteroclinic branches that connects the
saddle points
and so we follow our same procedure
to learn an atlas with six charts
and uh i should also mention that we use
this sort of uh special method from this
paper uh in pre from london and graham
uh to actually train our auto encoders
where we use uh it's like a combination
of pca and neural networks to to get a
special autoencoder structure
but in the end what we're able to do is
get this atlas with six charts and we
can get a three-dimensional dynamical
model that's
very qualitatively correct but a little
bit off quantitatively okay so we see a
qualitatively correct minimal
dimensional model but there is a
quantitative discrepancy in the length
of the quiescent periods so you can see
that
we don't stay on the cells for as long
as we do in the true dynamical system
but this is something that we believe is
actually inherent to the system itself
so
there's a logarithmic
divergence that's a sodium associated
with these two saddle points and so this
is something that would be
uh difficult to learn for for any model
not just the one that we've developed
here
but in any case you can see that we're
certainly getting uh the right behavior
we have the the state space
the space state structure looks correct
um
and if you look at
the statistics that you get from the
system it's also correct
okay
and so i think a really important
question asked is how does this actually
compare to previous methods
and so here there's actually some theory
that becomes very relevant so there's a
theorem that's known as the strong
whitney embedding theorem
and
essentially what it tells us is that
if you don't use an atlas of charts if
you don't break things up into patches
you should still be able
to reduce the dimension to 2n in the
worst case
so in this last example that i showed
where we believe that the true dimension
is three
if we don't break things up into patches
we should still be able to reduce the
dimension to six and capture uh the same
sort of behavior that we're able to
capture with our minimal uh patched
model
but when we actually try to do that
and
train a six-dimensional model just using
a single auto encoder without uh without
patching things up
what we find is that
we get something that isn't even
qualitatively correct
so what we get is something that's just
attracted it has this attractive fixed
point that's not even on the manifold
that the data lives on
and if you
look at the reconstruction error that
you get using a six dimensional
no chart model versus our our approach
where we're patching things up
then you see that our approach uh
consistently gets an order of magnitude
better reconstruction
than if you use no charts and in
particular the comparison that you
should be making is
the three-dimensional model that we have
with our patching approach versus the
six dimensional model that you get
without using patches and since
whitney's embedding theorem says that
these should be able
you know in principle to to work to do
just as well
but what we see is
even when we use uh six dimensions
and we use the same number of trainable
parameters
we still do an order of magnitude worse
when we don't patch things up compared
to when we patch things up and so
we're actually getting
benefits
practical benefits beyond what you might
expect
from the theory that's provided by
whitney
okay so just to summarize quickly
inspired by differential geometry we
developed this atlas of charts based
approach to learn
simple
so the simplest dynamical models
directly from data
and our approach
it works by learning a patchwork of
local models and then sewing them
together to get global dynamics and
we've seen that this is able to
outperform global methods uh
even give us something reasonable where
global methods just just fail completely
and i'll just close by noting three
major benefits of this approach so
the first one i've been sort of harping
on the whole talk which is the ability
to obtain dynamical models of the lowest
possible possible dimension of the
intrinsic dimension of the system
the second is a sort of divide and
conquer approach leads to computational
benefits that include
scalability the ability to adapt models
locally
and an algorithm that's embarrassingly
paralyzable since all the patches are
treated independently during uh the
training phase
and also uh
this has the ability to separate state
space into regions of distinct behavior
so you might have
like a turbulent bursting system for
example you might have regions of state
space that have widely different
behavior and so you could be
advantageous to have
different models for each of those
different regions and then sort of patch
them together
and uh just as a final note even though
we've used neural networks here
at least from a practical standpoint you
can just use any other regression
approach that you like so neural
networks aren't necessarily required to
make this work
okay so uh with that i'd like to thank
everyone for listening to my talk and
i'm
very happy to take any questions that
you might have
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk uh indeed there is a
another question by pat
he asked have you compared your approach
to methods that include governing
equation directly there has been lots of
work on that sorry could you repeat that
again have you compared your approach to
methods that induce
governing equations
directly
uh okay so maybe pat could tell me what
sort of methods you have in mind
well sure so there's been a
there's been 40 years of work on trying
to discover
a laws numeric laws and models from from
data stated in established scientific
formalisms but just in the past six
years or so there's been a bunch of
people that that started working on this
right and so they they have data times
series data and the output is a set of
equations that describe the dynamics and
and it that sounds like you you said you
compared your approach to
global methods but which and these are
certainly global methods but it doesn't
sound like
that you i didn't hear you say that you
were comparing to these techniques
so rather than rather than building a
bunch of local patches you you come up
with one set of laws that describe
everything for example for your simple
circle example you would you would
discover an equation or a differential
equation
set of differential equations to
describe the change
or you could use existing equations if
you happen to know
of course if you know them but but but
there are well established techniques
for discovering them from from the data
yeah so so the key distinction is uh
breaking things up into patches
and that gives you the ability to uh
to get up to get the minimal dimensional
system that you possibly can so that's
really the only distinction you can use
actually all these other things
my question is
is uh for i don't know if you mean what
you mean by minimal here because if you
come up with like say two equations to
describe the circle you don't need
patches at all right there's one patch
uh yeah so
so when you said that you compared your
approach to global methods i it sort of
sounded like you were talking about that
but i don't think you were is that
correct
uh no that that's correct so you're
right you can come up with a system of
two differential equations for the
circle right
but you cannot come up with a
system well a system of one if you do
everything at once if you treat the
circle as a whole oh i see
so the point here is when you break it
up into patches you can come up with
a one-dimensional system
and why is that more desirable than
having two simple differential equations
uh yeah so uh in some cases uh you can
get drastically better performance by by
getting something that's lower
dimensional so in this last example that
i showed actually right where i had this
sort of uh
you know bursting behavior
there um we got something qualitatively
correct with these local
three-dimensional models
whereas when we try to just learn
a set of six differential equations for
the entire data
you know for the entire data center for
the entire system
even though in theory that should have
worked it actually failed completely and
gave us something that was even
qualitatively off
okay i think i understand now uh
what you're what you're talking about
you're claiming that in some cases there
are hidden variables that could describe
systems in a smaller
number of dimensions than even than even
the
the uh equations themselves okay now
they you may lose interpretability in
the process uh and that may or may not
be a price you want to pay that's okay i
just wanted to understand what your
position is and i do understand it now
uh thank you
i i also put a bunch of links in in the
in the chat box about
locally
locally weighted learning
local linear regression
this is
this is very similar in spirit to your
approach
except that it doesn't require you to
identify patches what happens is each
time you have a new test case you find
you you find
the nearest n
points
and then you do local regression on
those points
and i do think that
that you want to you will want to
compare your approach to that it goes
back to the to the mid mid 1990s and uh
there's a survey paper uh that i that i
put in the chat box that's worth
pursuing
okay yeah yeah so i i have seen i i
can't see the links right now but i have
taken a look at some of these works from
the 90s
and
one thing that i've seen basically in
all the ones that i saw that do these
sort of local models is that even though
they
treat things locally
implicitly they still try to build a
global coordinate system from these
local models so yeah one work from brand
for example who's the first person to
mention analysis of charts and so even
even if you treat things locally but
still try to get a global coordinate
system in the end you fall into the same
problem that you do with these global
methods well the i think the standard
story would be that they are creating a
lower dimensional manifold
through the space uh by by doing this
but i i grant you that there's a sense
in which
they they certainly aren't inferring the
the latent variables that you are um so
so i agree there's a difference although
hearing your talk the first time that
that was the first thing that left to my
mind and i do think you should you want
to you want to make sure to distinguish
your approach from that because it
superficially seems very closely related
yeah uh
okay fair enough i know what you mean
and i'll take a look at those papers
thank you thanks
sounds good is there any other questions
from audiences
okay from scott um okay there's another
okay so the first question from scott
how robust is your method to noise in
the data
yeah um so
uh
we haven't checked this explicitly but
it would be
as robust as
as any auto encoder model is the one
thing that will be a little bit tricky
is
in transitioning from one patch to
another so if you have noisy data then
you're probably going to get
you know where the two manifolds
intersect
the disagreement will probably be higher
when you have noisy data and so when you
transition from one to another you might
get
something that's not smooth there
but otherwise
you inherit the same properties that
auto encoders have
all right sounds good um
another question i think i missed the
question
one question before
right a question from
ps
can you give some intuition as to why
k-means
is the right way to cover the data with
patches since k-means is used to
optimize an
objective that may have little to do
with the right way to determine the
patches
yeah that's a fair question
and
i make no claims that k-means is the
right way to go uh
it's a convenient thing that should
scale well
um and that's the main reason that we
used it but there could be much better
ways to actually come up with how to
come up with a decomposition into
patches
i'm actually very interested in what
could be better ways to do that
so very happy
to hear any uh comments or suggestions
if someone could email those to me all
right sounds good okay uh
great another question from harshit
uh thank for the nice talk can you
provide more details about
transitioning from one pass to
another
how is the transition constructed and
how do we detect
when one needs to go from one test to
another
yeah okay so uh
the way that we've been doing it so far
is when we have
when we perform our initial
decomposition
into patches
each data point is
uniquely assigned to a patch right so
k-means uniquely assigns
each point to a cluster
and then we do a little procedure where
we start to make these
these patches overlap with each other
so when we do that there are points now
that might belong to multiple patches
and so here uh here we develop a notion
of internal points and boundary points
so a data point is
internal to a patch if it was assigned
to that patch during the initial
clustering procedure
a data point is
external to a patch or it's on the
boundary of a patch if it was assigned
to that patch during the
during the overlap procedure so imagine
we start with some patch
it contains some data points and then we
expand that patch outward during that
expansion process
it uh you know some other points are
assigned to that patch and those points
are considered
external or boundary points in that
patch
so
uh the way that transitions work is
uh
as we're evolving our state forward in
time
we search for uh the nearest training
point to the current state
if that nearest training point is an
internal point we stay in that patch
if the nearest point is an external or
boundary point then we switch to the
other patch and the reason that we can
do that is because
a point that is a boundary or exterior
point of one patch
will be uniquely interior to a different
patch and so we know that we should be
switching from one patch to another
so i don't know if that helped but but
we do have a preprint that sort of
explains it in in more detail as well
but that's that's how we do it
sounds good to me okay another question
from
tolu
he asked can the patching approach be
used to capture behavior dependent on
the long-range order
not sure what it means by long-range
order but
what do you know not sure either
hey uh
would you qualify
your questions all right uh
i meant like um
can the passing approach be used to
capture the
dynamics that is i guess pervasive
globally
like
not just local behavior but like the
global behavior
uh do you have an example in mind
um so i guess um
for example um i don't know if this is
really relevant but like
i'm from a chemistry background and if
you do like molecular dynamic
simulations sometimes the behavior of
the atoms uh they're governed by a
uh a long range governing
type of equation so
i was wondering if the passing approach
can be used to like capture those kinds
of um dynamics
yeah in principle yes so the patching is
done in state space and uh and what
you're describing are these long-range
interactions in physical space okay but
everything done is done in state space
so that should
this method should be able to capture
that and then any other method should be
able to to capture that as well as long
as it's in state space
all right sounds good
i don't see any other questions now
is there any other questions
if not we can thank our speaker today
for the wonderful talk i i do it was
really uh interesting talk so
i'd like to
have a
you know
follow on the meeting with you
personally but other than that thank you
so much um danielle for the wonderful
talk all right thank you everyone
all right thank you everyone for joining
today
okay